I'm loving the season so far so many
heartfelt moments so many intense
moments I just want to jump right into
it Madeline Sarah looks like she's in
for a crazy bumpy ride this season her
relationship with John B a relationship
with topper her relationships
yeah you know all the relationships
going on what can you tell us about her
journey this season uh I mean this
season is really just a big big season
for Sarah's emotional recall like the
first season and the second season were
crazy crazy rides for her and I always
really wanted to take just like
slow it down even just the smallest bit
and kind of look inward with Sarah and
just see how like check in on how she's
doing because
with such crazy things she's been
through you can't not have some sort of
like built up anything and I think this
season you see all of that come to a
head and you know there's you know
there's really adult Dynamics and lots
of you know very human emotion that
comes with these relationships and these
friendships and you know you really just
see her kind of like trying to fight a
very moral battle
um you know especially between like the
world she was raised in and like the
family that she's now chosen
all the relationships for a 17 16 17
year old girl
speaking of relationships Madison I want
to ask you because you know the fans
have been wanting it between key and JJ
and I'm thinking it might come this
season we see some moments so what can
you tell us about working with Rudy and
and growing that deeper connection with
him yeah
um
AJ feel like characters that are really
good friends with really good chemistry
and I think we're trying to explore that
and navigate where that lands us with
like you know The Pogues meaning more to
us than anything but
knowing that we mean something to each
other in a in a different way so it's
been fun to explore this season you know
there's been a lot of
a lot of ups and push and pull yeah yeah
I'd love to see the fans love to see it
for sure yeah and carlosia Cleo my girl
I gotta ask you know that's my girl but
um not a big role in season two but much
bigger role in season three what was it
like for you to come back with the cast
and just be much more involved this
season oh it's been amazing it's been so
exciting
um it's such a fun ride I feel like you
know now I'm like officially officially
a part of the family and it's been it's
been so great
um to really just jump in and be
officially poke now and a part of the
family so it's been great it's been
really really amazing
that's awesome though you say that
because I wanted to ask you guys quickly
in your real lives which which one of
you would be more Pogue more Kook in
your real lives which ones which what
what what what what side are you going
on and you realize are you a little bit
more bougie a little bit you know more
laid back oh I'm a bougie girl I like I
like nice things I like I like clean
things yeah
I'm a little bit of both I'm a little
bit of both like I'm cooking some way
and I'm poking somewhere yeah yeah yeah
okay yeah me too I feel the same way
honestly yeah so so Madeline if you were
to give an overall Vibe of this season
for the fans that are expecting to to
watch it coming up in a couple weeks
what is your main takeaway from this
season for the fans
God main takeaway
um
friendships relationships action Stakes
all of it we've just we just put it in
warp speed this season
I love that I love that well thank you
guys so much I appreciate you taking the
time thank you looking forward to seeing
the rest of the season thank you so much